let's go next to our caller from the 401
area code who's calling today 401 it is
you the wind is louder than your voice
so we want to reverse that as much as
possible hear me now yeah that's a
little better who's this this is Jon
McKamey from Rhode Island
hey Jon what's going on today report
this did you see that video where Bill
Maher said last year that he wants a
recession so Donald Trump doesn't get
reelected what are your thoughts on that
yeah I mean those are not my approaches
like I don't I think that yes Donald
Trump is doing immeasurable damage to
the country but you know hoping for a
recession which could send people into
financial distress the likes of which it
could be decades before they recover if
at all in order to remove a president I
mean I have a different view which is we
should be able to remove from for the
things that have gone wrong we shouldn't
need a recession in order to justify
doing it I understand the idea though
that empirically if if you have a what's
considered a good economy very often the
incumbent president does get reelected
so I sort of understand what he's
getting at but I don't agree with that
yeah I pretty much agree I mean I
understand where he's coming from but I
think it's wrong just to root for a
recession just to get rid of Donald
Trump you know what I mean yeah I mean
listen I'm hoping for things to happen
that will get Trump removed it's like I
wish we had an electorate that actually
had some sense of decency and understood
the embarrassing reality of Trump as
president you know like I don't have to
wish for if we're just wishing for
things we can't actually control I'd
rather a smarter electorate that
wouldn't elect this clown in the first
place oh boy listen I'm gonna let you go
it's crazy I hope you're not being
dragged under by a rogue wave in the
ocean
but it's very loud I know you're gone
from Rhode Island you might be literally
standing in the ocean so I'm gonna let
you go and we will maybe hear back from
you at some point